You know what I love?
*holy music* Yasss
Oh my God!  Ohhh!
High-five girl!
Yes, self esteem is great, but even more than that
I love hanging out with my homies.
So when I go on Facebook and I see that they have all hung out without me,
I get sad.
*Haunted house piano*
Sometimes my feelings of being left out are totally justified.
Why wasn't I invited to the family reunion?
And sometimes they're not.
Why wasn't I invited to your bachelor party?
You're...not a dude?
I get so worried about being, like, excluded from something or forgotten about
that sometimes I try to preemptively get myself invited to things.
Oh yeah, I heard about this really cool place in Malibu where you can do Go-karts.
*gasps*
Oh my God!  That sounds like so much fun!
We should do it!  We should all go together like, as friends
and hang out and do that.
Lets do it.
Why don't we put it on the books right now?
Like, I have Tuesday night free.
What about you guys?
Get out your phones.
Look at your schedules.
Lets make a plan!
But then I realize how stupid this is
because none of my friends are going to intentionally exclude me from anything.
Like, if they don't invite me maybe they just don't think its my jam
or maybe it was a mistake.
I know these things can happen.
People just forget!
Cause I forgot 2 days ago.
I was throwing a party and my friend heard about it and messaged me
and she was like hey I heard you were having this party and I'm not invited.
Totally understand if you don't want me there
But I think you just forgot about me?
And she was right!
I totally did and I felt so bad and I apologized and invited her.
But it kind of changed the way that I think about it, you know?
I was like: "Oh
now instead of feeling sad and left out when people forget to invite me to things,
I'm just going to plan as many activities as possible
so that I'm constantly hanging out with people as much as I can stand them.
*Evil sound plays*
Is this good advice?
I don't know!
But it's really working for me right now!
I'm Anna Akana.
Stay awesome Goth(am)....
Yas! I wanna say thank you to Audible for sponsoring today's episode.
Audible is offering all of us girls and guys a chance to try them out for free
for 30 days
They have a immense selection of audio books,
original shows
news, comedy and more!
And you can listen anywhere, girl!
You can learn anywhere you want!
While you're driving, while you're eating, while you're putting on your makeup
while you are taking out the trash
if you do that of your household because yas girl!
Empowerment!
Currently, I'm listening to Hidden Figures,
the American dream and the untold story of the black women mathematicians
who help win the space race because yas girl!
Yas!
The story of how they over came their struggles is like
totes inspiring and empowering for me
as a woman.
So you can go ahead and try Audible.com/Anna for a free 30 day trial and a free Audiobook!
Yas!  Yas!
That is Audible.com/Anna.
Yas, girl.
*blows kiss*
Bye girl.